foreign
how can we help you yeah so my wife and
I are on baby step seven kids are
through school houses paid no debts
about two years ago we maxed out our
401k and Roth and everything else as
full as we could then the market of
course went South and we decided to back
off to 15 on our 401ks we focused on
cash and putting a little money into our
house remodel
and the question is when do we get back
in what's a good sign
okay the wrong question
um the the right question is should I
have done that no you should not
um because there is all kinds of data
points all kinds of pieces of research
and you can go back through and study
the history of the stock market of
people who try to do what you're doing
which is called timing the market I'm
going to get out when it's high and in
when it's low would be the theory but
most people do quite the opposite of
that because they're emotionally driven
and they get out when it's low
and back in when it's high oh it's great
I'm getting in well it's exactly the
wrong time so the people if you compare
mathematically people that jump in and
out and try to catch those waves with
people who just get in and stay in
they are the ones that get in and stay
and outperform them about 40 percent
it's crazy how much the math changes so
that's why we always say no one gets
hurt on a roller coaster except those
that jump off in the middle so what I
would tell you is any time that you're
not in the market is a good time to get
in and then stay in and and so the other
thing is the market is down right now
and all but one time in the last 100
years when the market has been down the
year following is excellent and so if
you were going to violate all that stuff
I just said a minute ago and try to time
the market now's an excellent time to be
investing because it's on sale right now
you're at you're we used to when I was a
kid we'd go to Kmart anybody remember
Kmart come on and uh they put these blue
lights up and they're like special you
know and uh and it's on sale and that's
what the market is when it goes down
it's on sale and you want to get in for
sure yeah and the thing about that is
you know the Market's always fluctuating
but as long as you stay on you're on the
ride the moment you get out and sell
you're locking in that loss and so
you've just taken that you've officially
taken the hit once you get out and so
that's why I mean just stay in it
because it's going to adjust it's normal
and I think that's the thing that folks
need to get in their head these
adjustments it's normal it's cyclical
this is what we should expect we
shouldn't expect for it to just be
skyrocketing all the time it's
constantly changing and adjusting but we
know by looking at you know the history
and track record that although it going
and fluctuating it's always tracking
upward even though it's adjusting so
that's really that gives me peace at
night and uh you know we're all in here
with you and we're keeping our money in
the market man amen thank you Kevin good
question John I had a yeah
[Applause]
I read a piece of research and I'm
curious your take on this as a as a PhD
in counseling that there's something
about the human brain that the the
financial people have found with surveys
that it takes three dollars of gain to
emotionally offset the damage that one
dollar of loss did yeah I I think it may
even be more than that now
um but it it takes we're so loss averse
that's just the way our bodies are
designed because they're over so many
thousands of years there was so much
scarcity so it's just designed for
um hanging on to loss hanging on the
loss and man it takes a it takes some
gain to get back to that equilibrium and
even then your body puts a GPS pin in
that loss and it always wants you to
remember remember that time you lost
remember the time we lost remember tell
me lost and that works with money that
works with your marriage that works with
your kids that works with traum all that
stuff is your body's trying to remind
you well and what ends up happening is
then we uh the little drama queen that
lives inside of us overstates this crap
my drama queen is incredible
so loud
here's what I know about me I get hyper
emotional about this stuff and so
literally once a quarter when the the
things are coming out my smart investor
Pro will call me and say you're going to
get some mail
probably don't open it you're good
you're good and I'll say well what does
that mean it says you're good right but
this is I I've actually had to Outsource
on there like their little Outlook a
little Tickler call John talk to him
that's yes well they know I'm gonna call
them with a hundred questions that I got
off of YouTube like oh oh yeah what if
the dollar goes away and we're trading
rocks and what and he's like dude I'm
just gonna call him
that that is what happens but then
people say things like well you know in
08 I lost everything in the stock market
I didn't no you did and if you did it's
because you exactly it's not possible
because you're still here unless you had
it in a single stock and that company
went broke but if you were in mutual
funds you did not lose everything it's
mathematically impossible it it actually
only went in half that's true she only
lost half and you didn't even lose half
unless you happen to bail out at exactly
the bottom which is a a unique ability
to get out at exactly the bottom
that's one of my gifts Dave it's one of
my gifts
so the trick is it's it
I think over the years I'm watching this
stuff personal finance is 80 behaviors
20 head knowledge and over the years of
watching this stuff the way I have
learned to overcome the inner drama
queen is just an act of my intellectual
will I'm going to use my freaking brain
instead of the drama queen that says the
world's coming to an end and
you know I've got to look at the actual
data points and say
jumping in and out bad staying in good
for a hundred freaking years you know
and we've always had incompetent
presidents we've always had a Congress
that was handcuffed to itself we've
always none of these things are new
here's what is I think new
is this idea that the news is here to
help us the news has one job and that's
to get your attention that's right and
it gets your attention when it says
you're gonna die and so you you click on
it the news is not here to give you info
it's here to make you wild right it's
not your friend not your friend this is
the Ramsey Show